noted philosopher here at MIT maybe you
were right this when uber drivers wrote
a paper about 1963 in which he alleged
had a subject had a heading titled
computers can't play chess of course he
was subsequently invited over to the
artificial intelligence laboratory to
play the Greenblatt chess machine and of
course he lost whereupon Seymour Pavan
wrote a rebuttal to drive us his famous
paper in which had a subject heading
Dreyfus can't play chess either but in a
strange sense Dreyfus might have been
right and would have been right if he
were to have said computers can't play
chess the way humans play chess yet in
any case around about 1968 a chess
master and David Levy bet noted founder
of artificial intelligence John McCarthy
that no computer would beat the world
champion within ten years and five years
later McCarthy gave up because it had
already become clear that no computer
would win in a way that McCarthy wanted
it to win that is to say by playing
chess the way humans play chess but then
20 years after that in 1997 deep blue
beat the world champion and chess
suddenly became uninteresting but we're
going to talk about games today because
there are elements of gameplay that do
model some of the things that go on in
our head and if they don't model things
that go on in our head they do model
some kind of intelligence and if we're
to have a general understanding of what
intelligence is all about we have to
understand that kind of intelligence too
so we'll start off by talking about
various ways that we might design a
computer program to play a game like
chess
and we'll conclude by talking a little
bit about what deep blue adds to the ads
the next other than tremendous speed so
that's our agenda by the end of the hour
you'll understand and be able to write
your own deep blue if you feel like it
first we want to talk about how it might
be possible for a computer to play chess
so let's talk about several approaches
it might be possible approach number one
is that the machine might make a
description of the board same way a
human would talk about pawn structure
King safety whether it's a good time to
castle that sort of thing so it would be
analysis and perhaps some strategy mixed
up with some tactics and all that would
get mixed up and finally result in some
kind of move so if this is the game
board to move the next thing to do would
be determined by some process like that
in trouble is no one knows how to do it
and so in that sense Dreyfus is right
know the game playing programs today
know how incorporate any of that kind of
stuff so since nobody has to do it knows
how to do that we can't talk about it so
we can talk about other ways though that
we might try for example we could have
if then rules
how would that work that would work this
way you look at the board represented by
this note here and you say well if the
if it's possible to move the Queen Pond
forward by one then do that so it
doesn't do any valuation of the board it
doesn't try anything
it just says let me look at the board
and select a move on that basis so that
would be a way of approaching a game
situation like this here's the situation
here the possible moves and one is
selected on the basis of an if-then rule
like so and nobody can make a very
strong chess player that works like that
curiously enough someone has made a
pretty good checkers playing program
that move that works like that checks to
see what moves are available on the
board ranks them picks the highest one
that's available but in general that's
not a very good approach it's not very
powerful you couldn't make it well when
I say couldn't means I can't think of
any way that you could make a strong
chess playing program that way so the
third way to do this is to look ahead
and evaluate
and what that means as you look ahead
like so you see all the possible
consequences of moves and you say which
of these board situations is best for me
so so that would be an approach that
comes in here like so and says which one
of those three situations is best and do
that we have to find have to have some
way of evaluating the situation deciding
which of those is best now I want to do
a little brief aside because I want to
talk about the mechanisms that are
popularly used to do that a kind of
evaluation in the end there are lots of
features of the chess board let's call
them f1 f2 and so on and we might form
some function of those features and that
overall is called the static value so
it's static because you're not exploring
any consequences of what might happen
you're just looking at the board as it
is checking the King's safety checking
the pawn structure each of those
produces a number feeds into this
function out comes a value and that is a
value of the board seen from your
perspective now normally this function G
is reduced to a linear polynomial so in
the end the most popular kind of way of
forming a static value is to take F 1
multiply it times some constant C 1 add
C 2 multiplied times F 2 and that is a
linear scoring polynomial
so we could use that function to produce
numbers from each of these things and
then pick the highest number and that
would be a way of playing the game
actually a scoring polynomial is a
little bit more than we need because all
we really need is a method that looks
with those three boards and says I like
this one best it doesn't have to rank
them it doesn't have to give the numbers
all has to say which one it likes best
so one way of doing that is to use a
linear scoring polynomial but it's not
the only way of doing that so that's
number two number three but now what
else might we do well if we reflect back
on some of the searches we talked about
what's the base case against which
everything else is compared what's the
way of doing search that doesn't require
any intelligence just brute force we
could use the British Museum algorithm
and simply evaluate the entire tree of
possibilities I move you move I move you
move all the way down to all the way
down to what maybe 150 moves you would
do 50 things I do 50 things so before we
can decide if that's a good idea or not
we probably ought to develop some
vocabulary
so consider this tree of moves there
will be some number of choices
considered at each level and there'll be
some number of levels so the standard
language for this is to call this the
branching factor and in this particular
case B is equal to 3 this is the depth
of the tree and in this case D is 2 so
now that produces us a certain number of
terminal or leaf nodes how many of the
how many of those are there well that's
pretty simple computation right it's
just B to the D right Christopher B to
the D so if you have e to the D at this
level you have one B to the D at this
level you have B give B to the D at this
level you have B squared so B to the D
in this particular case is not so now we
can use this vocabulary we've developed
to talk about whether it's reasonable to
just do the British Museum algorithm be
done with it
forget about chess and go home well
let's see it's about if it's pretty it's
pretty deep down there if we think about
chess and we think about a standard game
which each person does 50 things that
gives a D of about a hundred and if you
think about the branching factor in
chess it's generally presumed to be
depending on the stage of the game and
so on and so forth it varies but it
might average around
14 or 15 if it were just 10 that would
be 10 to the hundredths right it's a
little more than that because the
branching factor is more than 10 so in
the end it looks like according to
Claude Shannon there are about 10 to 100
to the 120th leaf nodes down there and
if you're going to do a British Museum
treatment of this tree you'd have to do
10 to the 120 estatic evaluations down
there at the bottom if you're going to
see which one of the moves is best at
the top so is that a reasonable number
you know it didn't used to seem it
didn't use to seem practicable it used
to seem impossible but now we've got
cloud computing everything and maybe we
could actually do that right what do you
think Manasseh can you do that get
enough computers going in the cloud you
know you're not sure so we work it out
let's work it out I'll me I need some
help especially from any of you were
studying cosmology so we'll start with
how many atoms are there in the universe
volunteers 10 to the no no no it's 10 to
the 38th has been offered that's why -
its way too low last time I look is
about 10 to the 80th atoms in the
universe now the next thing I'd like to
know is how many seconds are there in a
year it's a good number to have in your
you know memorize and that number is
approximately PI times 10 to the seventh
okay so how many nanoseconds in a second
that gives us 10 to the knife Oh last
how many years are there in the history
of the universe
she offers something on the order of 10
billion maybe 14 billion will say 10
billion to make our calculation simple
so that's 10 to the 10th years so if we
add all that up 8090 plus 16 that's 10
to the 106 here at 10 to the 100 and 6th
nanoseconds in the history of the
universe multiplied times the number of
atoms in the universe so if all of the
atoms in the universe were doing static
evaluations at nanosecond speeds since
the beginning of the Big Bang would
still be 14 orders of magnitude short so
be pretty good cloud would have to
harness together lots of universes so
the British Museum algorithm is not
going to work
no good so what we're going to have to
do is we're going to have to put some
things together and hope for the best so
the fifth way is the way we're actually
going to do it what we're going to do is
we're going to look ahead not just one
level but as far as possible so we
consider not only the situation that
we've developed here but we'll try to
push that out as far as we can and look
at these look at the static values of
the leaf nodes down here and somehow use
that as a way of playing the game so
that is number five number four is going
all the way down there and this in the
end is all that we can do this idea is
multiple invented most notably by Claude
Shannon and also by Alan Turing who I
found out from a friend of mine spent a
lot of lunch time conversations they
spent a lot of lunchtime conversations
talking with each other about how a
computer might play chess and it gives
the future when their work would be
computers so Donald Michie and Alan
Turing also invented this over lunch
while they were taking some time off
from breaking it from cracking the
German codes well what is the method
I want to illustrate the method with the
simplest possible tree so we're going to
have a branching factor of two not 14
and we're going to have a depth of two
not something hi Lisa
so here's the game tree and they're
going to be some numbers down here at
the bottom and these are going to be the
value of the board from the perspective
of the player at the top I let us say
that the player the top would like to
drive the play as much as possible
toward the big numbers so we're going to
call that player the maximizing player
he would like to get over here to the
eight because that's the biggest number
there's another player here's a poet
which we'll call the minimizing player
and he's hoping that the number that the
play will go down to the board situation
that's as small as possible because his
view is the opposite of the maximizing
player all right
hence the name minimax but how does it
work do you see which way the play is
going to go how would you decide which
way the play is going to go well it's
not obvious at a glance do you see which
way it's going to go it's not obvious at
a glance but if we do more than a glance
if we look at the situation from the
perspective of the minimizing player
here at the middle level it's pretty
clear that if the minimizing player
finds himself in that situation he's
going to choose to go that way and so
the value of this situation from the
perspective of the minimizing player is
two it never go over there to the seven
similarly if the minimizing player is
over here with a choice between going
toward a one or toward an eight he'll
obviously go toward a one and so the
value of that board situation from the
perspective of minimizing players want
so now we've taken the scores down here
at the bottom of the tree and we back
them up one level and you see how we can
just keep doing this now the maximizing
player
and see that if he goes to the left he
gets a score of two he goes to the right
he only gets to score of one so he's
going to go to the left and so overall
then the maximizing player is going to
have a two as the perceived value of
that situation there at the top so
that's the minimax algorithm is very
simple you go down to the bottom of the
tree you compute static values you back
them up level by level and then you
decide where to go in this particular
situation the Maximizer goes to the left
and the minimizer goes to the left too
so the play ends up here far short of
the eight that the Maximizer wanted and
less than the one that the minimizer
wanted but this is an adversarial game
you're competing with each other so you
don't expect to get what you want all
right so maybe we ought to see if we can
make that work there's a game treaty you
see how it goes so see if the system can
figure it out so there it goes crawling
its way through the tree this is a
branching factor of two just like our
sample but now four levels you can see
it's got quite a lot of work to do
that's two to the two to the fourth
that's one two three four to the fourth
sixteen static evaluations to do so it
found the answer but it's a lot of work
we could get a new tree and restart it
maybe speed it up
that goes down that way get a new tree
those are just random numbers so each
time it's going to find a different path
through the tree according to the
numbers that it's generated now 16 isn't
bad but if you get down there around 10
levels deep and you're branching
tractors 14 while we know those numbers
get pretty awful pretty bad because the
number of static evaluations do down
there at the bottom goes as B to the D
that's exponential and time has shown
that if you get down to about seven or
eight levels you're a jerk and you get
down to about fifteen or sixteen levels
you beat the world champion so you'd
like to get as far down in the tree as
possible because when you get as far
down to the into the tree as possible
what happens is that these crude
measures of board quality begin to
clarify and in fact when you get far
enough the only thing that really counts
is piece count one of those features so
if you get far enough piece count a few
other things will give you a pretty good
idea what to do if you get farther we're
getting far enough could be a problem
so we want to do everything we can to
get as far as possible we want it
thought every trick we can find to get
as far as possible now you remember when
we talked about branch and bound we knew
that there were some things we could do
that would cut off whole portions of the
search tree and so we'd like to do is
find something analogous to this world
of games they'll cuff whole portions of
the search tree so we don't have to look
at those static values so what I want to
do is I'm going to come back and redo
this thing but this time I'm going to
compute the static values one of the
time I've got the same structure in the
tree and just as before I'm going to
assume that the top player wants to go
toward the maximum values and the next
player wants to go toward the minimum
values but none of the static values
have been computed yet so I better start
computing them that's the first one I
find - now as soon as I see that - as
soon as the minimizer sees that - the
minimizer knows that the value of this
node can't be any greater than two
because I always choose to go down this
way if this branch produces a
bigger number so we can say that the
minimizer is assured already that a
score there will be less than two equal
to or less than two so now we go over
and hit the next number there's a seven
now I know it's exactly equal to because
I'll never go down toward seven as soon
as the minimizer says equal to two the
Maximizer says okay I can do equal to or
greater than two all right
one minimizer says equal to or less than
one
now what prepare those two numbers the
Maximizer knows if he goes down here he
can't do better than one it already
knows if he goes over here he can get it
too
so it's as if this branch doesn't even
exist because this the Maximizer would
never choose to go down there and so you
have to see that because this is the
important essence of the notion of alpha
beta of the Alpha Beta algorithm which
is a layering on top of minimax that
cuts off large sections of the search
tree so one more time
we've developed the situation so we know
that the Maximizer gets a two going down
to the left and he sees that if he goes
down to the right he can't do better
than one so he says to himself
it's as if that branch doesn't exist and
the overall score is two and it doesn't
matter what that static value is it can
be eight as it was it can be plus a
thousand it doesn't matter give me minus
a thousand or it could be plus infinity
or minus infinity it doesn't matter
because the Maximizer will always go the
other way so that's the Alpha Beta
algorithm can you guess why it's called
the Alpha Beta algorithm well because in
the algorithm there are two parameters
alpha and beta so it's important to
understand alpha beta is not an
alternative to minimax it's minimax with
a flourish
and something layered on top like we
layered things on top of
branch-and-bound to make it more
efficient we layer stuff on top of
minimax to make it more efficient how
you say to me well that's pretty easy
example under this so let's try a little
bit more complex one just just to see if
I could do it without screwing up all
right I reason I do it I reason I do
when this complex is not just to show
how tough I am in front of a large
audience but rather there are certain
points of interest and all they occur in
a tree of depth for greater that's the
reason for this example but work with me
let's see if we can get our what work
our way through it what I'm going to do
is all up I'll circle the static the
numbers that we actually have to compute
so we actually have to compute 8 as soon
as we do that the minimizer knows that
that node is going to have a score of
equal to or less than 8 without looking
anything else then he looks at 7 so
that's equal to 7 because the minimizer
will clearly go to the right as soon as
that is determined that the Maximizer
knows that the score here is equal to or
greater than 8 now we evaluate the 3 the
minimizer knows equal to or less than 3
oh sorry minimizer 7 yeah ok now what
happens well let's see the Maximizer
gets a 7 going that way can't do better
than 3 going that way so we got another
one of these cutoff situations it's as
if this branch doesn't even exist
so this static evaluation need not be
made and now we know that that's naughty
not merely equal to or greater than 7
but exactly equal to 7 and we can push
that number back up so that becomes
equal to or less than 7 okay you with me
so far
let's get over the other side of the
tree as quickly as possible so there's a
9 equal to or less than 9 8 equal to 8
push the 8 up equal 2
or greater than 8 so the minimizer can
go down this way and get a 7 will
certainly never go that way where the
Maximizer can get an 8 so once again
we've got to cut off and it's as if this
branch didn't exist and that means that
these static evaluations don't have to
be made and this value is now exactly 7
but there's a little one more thing to
note here and that is that not only do
we not have to make these static
evaluations down here but we don't even
have to generate these moves so we save
two ways both on static evaluation and I
move generation so this this is a real
winner this alpha-beta thing because it
saves an enormous amount of computation
well round the way now the Maximizer up
here is guaranteed equal to or greater
than 7 say buddy found the winning move
yet is it to the left I don't know we
better keep going because we don't want
to trust any Oracle's so let's see
there's a 1 we've calculated that the
minimizer can be guaranteed equal to or
less than 1 at that particular point and
I'll think about that for a while at the
top the Maximizer knows you can go left
and get a 7 the minimizer if the play
ever gets here can ensure that you've
been driving the situation to a board
number that's 1 so the question is with
the Maximizer ever permit that to happen
and the answer is surely not so over
here in the development of this side of
the tree we're always comparing numbers
at adjacent levels in the tree but
here's a situation where we're comparing
numbers that are separated from each
other in the tree and we've still
concluded that no further examination of
this node makes any sense at all this is
called deep cutoff
and that means that this whole branch
here might as well not exist and we
won't have to compute that's that a guy
alright so it looks I mean you have this
stare of disbelief which is perfectly
normal I have to reconvince myself every
time that this actually works but when
you think your way through it it is
clear that these computations that I
vexed out don't have to be made so let's
carry on see if we can complete this
equal to or less than eight eight equal
to eight because the other branch
doesn't even exist equal to or less than
eight and we compare these two numbers
do we keep going yes we keep going
because maybe the Maximizer can go to
the right and actually get to that eight
so we have to go over here and keep
working away there's a nine equal to our
less than nine another nine equal to
nine push that number up equal to or
greater than nine let's say minimizer
gets an eight going this way Maximizer
is ensured of getting a nine going that
way so once again we've got a cut off
situation it's as if this doesn't exist
those static evaluations are not made
this move generation is not made and
computation is saved all right so let's
see if we can do better on this very
example by using this alpha beta idea
I'll slow it down a little bit we'll
change the search type to minimax with
alpha beta we see two numbers on each of
those nodes now guess what they're
called we already know right there alpha
and beta so what's going to happen is
the algorithm proceeds through the trees
if those numbers are going to shrink
wrap themselves around the situation so
we'll start that up
so two static evaluations were not made
let's try a new tree two different ones
we're not made a new tree yet - still
again two different ones not made let's
see what happens when we use the
classroom example the one I did up there
let's make sure that I didn't screw it
up slow that down to one
whew same answer so you probably didn't
realize it at the start who could and in
fact the play goes down that way over
this way down that way and ultimately to
the 8th which is not the biggest number
and it's not the smallest number it's
the compromise number that's arrived at
virtue of the fact that this is an
adversarial situation so you say to me
how much how much energy how much work
do you actually save by doing this well
it is the case that in the optimal
situation if everything is ordered right
if God has come down and arranged your
tree in just the right way then the
approximate amount of work you need to
do the approximate number of static
evaluations performed it is
approximately equal to two times B to
the D over two we don't care about this
too
we care a whole lot about that too so
that's the amount of work that's done
it's B to the D over two instead of B to
the D what does that mean suppose that
without this idea I can go down seven
levels how far can I go down with this
idea fourteen levels so it's a
difference being a jerk in a world
champion so that however is only in the
optimal case when God has arranged
things just right but in practical
situations practical game situations it
appears to be the case experimentally
that the actual number is close to this
approximation for optimal arrangements
so you never not want to use alpha-beta
saves an amazing amount of time you can
look at it another way
suppose you suppose you go down to the
same number of levels how much less work
do you have to do well quite a bit the
square root is month right so another
way of looking at how it works
so we could go home at this point except
for one problem and that is that we
pretended that the branching factor is
always the same but in fact the
branching factor will vary with the game
state and will vary with the game so if
you factor how much computing you can do
in two minutes or however much time you
have for an average move then you can
see how deep can I go and you won't know
for sure because it depends on the game
so in the early days of game playing
programs
the game-playing program left a lot of
computation on the table because it
would make a decision in three seconds
and it might have made a much different
move if it used all the computation it
had available alternatively it might be
grinding away and after two minutes was
consumed it had no move and just did
something random so that's not that's
not very good but that's what I really
game-playing programs did because no one
knew how deep they could go so let's
have a look at the situation here and
say well here's a game tree it's a
binary grain tree that's level 0 that's
level 1 this is level D minus 1 and this
is level D so down here you have
situation looks like this and I've left
all the game tree out in between so how
many leaf nodes are there down here B to
the D right oh I'm going to forget about
alpha beta for a moment as we did only
looked at some of those optimal searches
we're going to add these things one one
at a time
so forget about alpha beta assume we're
just doing straight minimax in that case
we would have to calculate all these
static values down here at the bottom
and there are B to the D of those how
many are there at this next level up
well that must be B to the D minus 1 how
many fewer nodes are there at the second
of the last the penultimate level
relative to the final level well 1 over
B right so if I'm concerned about not
beating all the way through these
calculations at the D level I can give
myself an insurance policy by
calculating out what the answer would be
if I only went down to the D minus 1 t
minus 1 level all right see I get that
insurance policy it only cost me let's
say the branching factor is 10 how much
does that insurance policy cost me 10
percent of my computation
because I can do this calculation and
have a move in hand here at level D
minus one for only 1/10 amount of the
computation that's required to figure
out what I would do if I go all the way
down to the deep level okay is that
clear so this idea is extremely
important in its general form but we
haven't quite got there yet
because what if the branching factor
turns out to be really big and we can't
get through this level either what
should we do to make sure that we still
have a good move right we can do it at
the B -2 level so that would be up here
and at that level the amount of
computation would be B to the D minus 2
so now it's we've got a 10% plus 10% of
that and our knee-jerk is beginning to
beginning to form right what are we
going to do in the end to make sure that
no matter what we've got to move okay
what's that Christopher start from the
very first level and give ourself an
insurance policy for every level we try
to calculate but that might be real
costly so we better figure out if this
is going to be too big of an expense to
bear so let's see if we do what
Christopher suggests then the amount of
computation we need in our insurance
policy is going to be equal to one we're
going to do it up here at this level too
even though we don't need it just make
everything work out easy 1 plus B that's
getting our insurance policy down here
at this first level and we're going to
add V squared all the way down to B to
the D minus 1 so that's how much we're
going to do spend getting an insurance
policy at every level I wish to some of
that high school algebra right let's
let's just do it for fun
Oh
unfortunate choice of variable names BS
is equal to we're going to multiply all
those by B okay now we'll subtract the
first one from the second one which
tells us that the amount of calculation
needed for our insurance policy
is equal to B to the D minus one over B
minus one is that a big number we can do
a little algebra on that and say that B
to the D is a huge number so that minus
one doesn't count and B is probably ten
to fifteen so B minus one is essentially
equal to B so that's approximately equal
to B the D minus one so with a with an
approximation factored in the amount of
takes us the amount of computation
needed to insurance policy at every
level it's not much different from the
computation needs to get insurance
policy at just one level that ultimate
wanted so this idea is called
progressive deepening
and now we can visit our gold star let's
go star idealist and see how these
things match up with that first of all
the dead horse principal comes to the
fore when we talk about alpha beta
because we note with alpha beta that we
can get rid of a whole lot of the tree
and not do static evaluations now you
can do move generation that's the dead
horse we don't want to be there's no
point in doing that calculation because
it can't figure into the answer the
development of the progressive deepening
idea I like to think of as in terms of
the martial arts principle we're using
the enemy's characteristics against them
because of this exponential blow-up we
have exactly the right characteristics
to have a move available at every level
as an insurance policy against not being
through the next level and finally this
whole idea of progressive deepening can
be viewed as a prime example of what we
like to call any time algorithms that
always have an answer ready to go as
soon as an answer is demanded so as soon
as that clock runs out at two minutes
some answer is available it'll be the
best one that the system can compute in
the time available given the
characteristics of the game tree as it's
developed so far so there are other
kinds of anytime algorithms this is an
example of one so that's how all game
playing programs work minimax + alpha
beta + progressive deepening Christopher
is alpha beta a alternative to minimax
no it's not it's something you layer on
top of minimax does alpha beta give you
a different answer from minimax
let's see right see everybody shake your
head one way or the other it does not
give you an answer different from any
nice that's right it gives you exactly
the same answer not a different answer
it's a speed up it's not an
approximation it's a speed up it cuts
off lots of the tree it's dead horse
principal at work okay oh that's one
suggestion that Christian is just I
think if I could jump ahead a couple
steps I think Christopher has reinvented
a very important idea progressive
deepening not only ensures that you get
a better answer progressive deepening
not only ensures you have an answer at
any time it actually improves the
performance of alpha beta when you layer
alpha beta on top of it because these
values that are calculated at
intermediate parts of the tree are used
to reorder the nodes under the tree so
as to give you maximum alpha beta cough
I think that's what you've said
Christopher but if it isn't we'll talk
about your idea after class so this is
what every game-playing program does so
what how is deep deep blue different not
much so deep blue as of 1997 did about
200 million static evaluations per
second and it went down using alpha beta
went down about 14 15 16 levels so deep
blue was minimax
plus alpha beta plus progressive
deepening plus a whole lot of parallel
computing plus an opening book plus
special purpose stuff for the endgame
plus perhaps the most important thing an
even tree development so far we
pretended that the tree always goes out
in an even way to a fixed level but
there's no particular reason why that
has to be so some some situation down at
the bottom of the tree may be
particularly dynamic in the very next
move you might be able to capture the
opponent's Queen so in circumstances
like that you want to blow out a little
extra search so eventually you get to
the idea that there's no particular
reason to have the search go down to a
fixed level but instead you can develop
the tree in a way that gives you the
most confidence that you're backed up
numbers are correct and so that's the
most importantly extra flourish is added
by deep blue when it be cast off in 1997
and now we can come back and say well
you understand deep blue but is this a
model of anything that goes on in our
own heads is this a model of any kind of
human intelligence or is it a different
kind of intelligence and the answer is
mix right because we're often in
situations where we are playing a game
we're competing with another
manufacturer we have to think what the
other manufacturer will do in response
to what we do and down several levels on
the other hand is going down 14 levels
what you and chess players do when they
win the world champion chip
mmm doesn't seem even to them like
that's even a remote possibility they
have to do something different because
they don't have that kind of
computational horsepower this is doing
computation in the same way that a
bulldozer processes gravel
it's substituting raw power for
sophistication so when the human chess
master plays the game they have a great
deal of chess knowledge in their head
and they recognize patterns there are
famous experiments by the way that
demonstrate this in the following way
show a chess board to a chess master and
ask them to memorize it they're very
good at that as long as it's a
legitimate chess board if the pieces are
placed randomly they're no good at it at
all
so it's very clear that they developed a
repertoire of chess knowledge that makes
it possible for them to recognize
situations and play the game much more
like number one up there so deep blue is
manifesting some kind of intelligence
but it's not our intelligence is
bulldozer intelligence so it's important
to understand that kind of intelligence
too but it's not necessarily the same
kind of intelligence that we have in our
own head so that concludes what we're
going to do today as you know on
Wednesday we have a celebration of
learning which is familiar to if you
take a 309 one and therefore I will see
you on Wednesday all of you I have
mentioned
you
you